We just heard about a whole
range of impairment from Victor.
He explained how we can consider
four broad types of impairments.
Visual impairment, motor impairment,
hearing impairment,
cognitive impairment.
And he gave us some
examples of each of those.
One other thing he mentioned,
was that for each type of impairment,
it could be temporary,
permanent or situational.
So it really is the case that any
of us could experience one of these
impairments at any time, even if
only situationally or temporarily.
We're going to do some quizzes now,
for each impairment,
which of these categories
does that fall into?
Select all of the answers
you think apply.